[Musique]
c'est pas tous les prisonniers qui sont
des cas spéciales il y en a qui savent
utiliser leurs domaines leur cerveau et
voilà quoi ça va prouver que en prison
ils peuvent certaines détenus peuvent
s'en sortir
[Musique]
travailler dans un groupe ça peut
paraître évident mais c'est pas si
simple que ça pour de nombreuses
personnes détenues il faut apprendre à
communiquer sereinement avec les autres
à gérer ses émotions pour éviter de se
mettre en colère apprendre à trouver sa
place dans le groupe un peu par analogie
avec ce qui va se passer à la Libération
parce que trouver sa place dans la
société c'est pas si facile que ça
[Musique]
effectivement le fait que le restaurant
soit implanté dans la prison ça crée des
conditions particulières et difficiles
pour le public mais ça a créé aussi une
expérience qui va être
unique on n'a pas le droit au téléphone
portable ça va créer une déconnexion
bienvenue
effectivement il va falloir réserver
quatre jours en avance
ici on est en prison mais on n'est pas
tous des trafiquants tout est voleur
voyez on a moi personnellement j'ai fait
plus de 6 ou 7 métiers quand j'ai 21 ans
je me projeter j'ai pas une truc nouveau
vous voyez sortir pour pour refaire des
conneries non mais sortir pour envisager
peut-être d'être serveur vous travaillez
dans la restauration oui c'est un visage
[Musique]